er ist der weltweit bekannteste agenten
und eine der populärsten film ikonen
aller zeiten
[Musik]
bond james bond seine markenzeichen sind
legendär
casinospiele um hohe einsätze sportwagen
spezial gadgets und sein berühmter
trinkt geschüttelt nicht gerührt bond im
geheimdienst ihrer majestät mit der code
nummer 007 und der lizenz zum töten
sein schöpfer ihren fleming war im
zweiten weltkrieg selbst britischer
geheimagent
er gab bond seine ganzen interessen und
leidenschaften bond und flemming haben
beidem recht flüchtige affären mit
frauen
wer war sein james bond wirklich haben
manche berühmte 007 missionen wirklich
so stattgefunden was sind die echten
agenten abenteuer hinter der film
legende flemings marine geheimdienst hat
agenten in allen regionen in allen häfen
der welt und die größenwahnsinnigen bund
bösewichte mit ihren folter orgien und
weltherrschaft fantasien stecken echte
schurken dahinter er war kahlköpfig ein
schwergewicht schwitze ich physisch
abstoßend und sexuell abnormen manche
der echten geheimmission des krieges aus
den ian fleming später james bond
erweisen sich als gefährlicher als die
des filmhelden 007
[Musik]
eine der ikonischen szenen der bond
agenten abenteuer spiele in london
casinos um hohe einsätze gegen
feindliche schuppen
hauptschauplatz des ersten bond romans
von 1953 ist das casino royal
der titelgebende französische ort royal
iso ist fiktiv aber die hintergründe
sind real
in der welt der casinos und gentleman
spielclubs kannte bonn schöpfer ihn
fleming sich gut aus fleming war selbst
sehr erfahrener kartenspieler er war
mitglied eines londoner clubs in dem
speziell mit hohen einsätzen gespielt
wurde fleming vor mit der autofähre nach
frankreich vor dem krieg um dort zu
spielen weil es hier damals illegal war
er mochte die aufregung dabei erlebte
das drama das karten tasche
jeder spielt um große einsätze aber
jeder schweigt und gibt nichts preis
das ist etwas theatralisches am casino
spiel mit hohem einsatz dass er wirklich
genossen hat
steckt hinter james bond also in
wahrheit ian fleming selbst und wie viel
echtheits factor haben die berühmten 007
missionen wie casino royale
es wird aber später mal auf einem
steckbrief darauf hingewiesen was james
bond eigentlich ist und was sehr kurz da
hat sie was ja alles so kann und was er
so drauf hat und er wird beschrieben
dass von den narben im gesicht hat dass
er die die haare die ein paar locker so
ein bisschen ins gesicht hängen dass er
so schaaf kann die gesichtszüge hat dass
er athletisch ist dass er bis im größer
als 180 ist das ein guter messerwerfer
das gute pistolenschütze ist und dass er
eben alkohol trinkt wenn auch nicht
exzessiv sich für frauen interessiert
schriftsteller und marineoffizier ian
fleming hat einige seiner eigenen
eigenschaften eins zu eins auf seine
figur james bond übertragen was ihm
fleming james bond gab waren alle seine
hauptinteressen und holz ihnen vor
leidenschaftlich gern auto und bonns
großes hobby war sein auto geliehen
spielte leidenschaftlich gern golf und
wieder gibt es dazu eine wundervolle
szene in goldfinger über 30 seiten gibt
über ein unglaubliches golfspiel
er liebte es karten zu spielen bridge zu
spielen
auch das mag band er gab bond seine
eigenen leidenschaften und interessen im
zweiten weltkrieg ist fleming offizier
im britischen marine geheimdienst seine
code nummer 17 11 aus london koordiniert
er spionagemissionen weltweit auslands
reisen führen ihn zu alliierten
geheimdiensten und in agenten hochburgen
der neutralen zonen nach dem krieg auf
seinem anwesen in jamaika erzählt
fleming dass er im jahr 1941 in portugal
in ein casino spiel verwickelt war
wie bond zum geschehen selbst existieren
jedoch unterschiedliche versionen und
fleming sagte
wäre das nicht ein spaß wenn ich gegen
die spielen würde und denen ihr geld
abknöpfen
also wie eine art verdeckte operation
ganz so wie er sie später in casino
royale geschraubt und nach seiner
eigenen erzählung tat fleming das auch
und setzte sein ganzes reisegeld geben
der nazis im heutigen wert von 2.500 in
allen farben beschrieben
daraus habe er später die konfrontation
bond gegen bösewicht le chiffre in
casino royal reform so flemings
darstellung damit in einem casino in
frankreich sitzt und übermüdet es lange
am spieltisch gesessen hat
der geruch und rauch und schweiß in
einem casino um drei uhr morgens
erzeugen übelkeit der nerven verschleiß
vom spielen um hohe einsätze eine
mischung aus gier und angst und nervöse
anspannung wird dann unerträglich
[Musik]
anzutreten
es war nur eine verwirrung eine fantasie
in seinem kopf das james bond der beste
spieler des geheimdienstes genau das
getan hat
tatsächlich verliert bond auch zuerst in
casino royale und muss gerettet werden
von felix leiter dem amerikaner der ihm
sehr viel geld gibt erst dann gewinnt er
in casino royale mischt fleming einen
bunten cocktail aus fakten und fiktionen
aus echten kriegserlebnisse und müller
dran
fakt eins als marina agent besucht
fleming im krieg das portugiesische
casino herstellt
ein hotspot für agenten innerhalb
portugals war lissabon auch eine
wichtige station für alle
nachrichtendienste der deutsche abwehr
dienst hat einen wichtigen apa posten
dort es gab eine größere italienische
nachrichten station und auch die briten
waren
flemming besuchte 1941 estoril
es ist ein angenehmer ferienort ich war
dort westlich von lissabon an den ufern
des rio these das casino ist berühmt 2
als fleming 1941 in der story lässt gibt
es einen britischen agenten der mit
geheimdienst geldern die casino bank
springt nur ist das nicht ersetzt
sondern sein kollege kopper dusan pop
und dieser job oft gesagt ja ich bin
dabei gewesen das stimmt so nicht
fleming hatte was dazu erfunden heute
wissen wir im august 1941 beobachtet
fleming in estoril popov er als
doppelagent nicht vollstes vertrauen
genießt playboy popov ist in begleitung
einer kuh agentin zugleich seine
geliebte die leidenschaft für frauen
teilen beide echte agenten mit der figur
james bond
es gibt viele ähnlichkeiten zwischen
fleming und bond was frauen angeht bond
und flemming haben beide recht flüchtige
beziehungen zu frauen
keiner von beiden will sich binden wir
wissen dass beziehungen dass die ehe
nicht in bonns karten steht nicht seine
wahre bestimmung ist und wohl auch
niemals in den karten von flemming hätte
stehen sollen
in portugal im krieg sommer 1941 hat
playboy agent popov soeben einen
spionage kugel landet für den britischen
geheimdienst mi6 hat er die nazis
getäuscht und viel geld vom deutschen
militär geheimdienst erschlichen der
berüchtigten abwehr
wahrscheinlich hatten die briten in der
studie verbindungen zur deutschen abwehr
und man spionierte sich gegenseitig aus
was man dort versucht ist bestimmte
geschichten zu platzieren und
herauszufinden wer auf der anderen seite
bereit sein könnte mit einem
zusammenzuarbeiten
die deutschen agenten in portugal lässt
ob auf glauben er würde für sie unter
den alliierten viele spione anwerben
er erhält dafür von deutscher seite rund
40.000 us dollar nach heutigem wert über
eine halbe million popov nimmt das geld
mit nach estoril fleming und sein chef
admira godfrey haben wir in der studie
das casino besucht und das war ein
bekannter geselliger treffpunkt eine art
schmelztiegel von menschen aller art aus
ganz europa an jenem augustabend in
estoril wird fleming zeuge dieses
dramatischen baccara spiels bank ubert
ohne limit ein reicher kaufmann namens
dr blog hält die bank und spielt ohne
limit popov setzt das ganze
[Musik]
geheimdienstagent popov gewinnt 40.000
doch ein nazi war sein gegenspieler
nicht im gegenteil
bloch war jüdischen glaubens und vor den
nazis ins portugiesische exil geflohen
eine person wusste wie flemings eigenes
kasino spiel wirklich verlaufen war sein
geheimdienstchef godfrey den er nach
portugal begleitet hatte sein chef hat
mir all godfrey klette später auf dass
die geschichte etwas anders war und was
wirklich geschehen war
bei ihrem besuch in der studie und das
ist schon glaubhafter fleming und er
waren im casino und da waren betrunkene
portugiesische geschäftsleute und gegen
die hat fleming gespielt
james bond war eine art fantasiefigur
die ihn fleming gerne gewesen wäre
flemming selbst verbrachte in den
zweiten weltkrieg weitgehend hinter dem
schreibtisch in der admiralität
flemings weg in den geheimdienst war
verschlungen seiner figur 007 übertrug
er eine tragische biografie die eigenen
schicksalsschlägen bei den flemings
ähnelt also beide elternteile verloren
bei einem kletterunfall in den schweizer
bergen und wurde und das wird hier und
da mal in den filmen erwähnt aber
wirklich nur meist auch nur am rande
er wurde als er vom britischen
geheimdienst rekrutiert verlernen weise
es und weil alleine ist und weise
sozusagen der britische geheimdienst mit
gleich mal m und miss moneypenny also
weiter so eine art ersatzfamilie bilden
flemming selbst wächst als halbwaise auf
sein vater fiel im ersten weltkrieg an
der frankreich- front valentine fleming
und der ist in der an der französischen
front gefallen der nähe von der song und
der deutschen beschuss geraten und
gestorben
das war 1917 da war er gerade mal neun
jahre alt natürlich hat ihnen das schwer
getroffen ohne vater aufzuwachsen da war
die mutter dann plötzlich alleine
geforderten affin und nachdem er in der
schule nicht gerade heldentaten
verbracht hatte auch nicht an der
militärakademie sandhurst hatte er noch
nicht wirklich etwas aus seinem leben
gemacht
im londoner west end im mai 1939 erhält
den flemming eine neue chance bei einem
mittagessen mit einem admiral er solle
sich bereithalten für den kriegsfall es
geht um einen job im marine
nachrichtendiensten id der nebel
intelligence division ian fleming hatte
vor dem krieg auch als börsenmakler
gearbeitet
am finanzplatz london und mehr ein
playboy leben geführt
auf einmal wird er 1939 ausgewählt als
assistent des direktors des marine
nachrichtendienstes admiral john godfrey
dem vorbild für bonds chefin m
dort blieb er während des krieges das
war ein fall von gesucht gefunden
sein neuer arbeitsplatz die ort mrt der
imperial baukomplex der alten
admiralität damals das hauptquartier der
britischen kriegsmarine das ganze
gebiete an krieg voller stacheldraht und
sperber los der einzige zugang war von
trafalgar square
also nimmt fleming den eingang durch die
admira die art den triumphbogen an der
statue von captain cook vorbei über den
großen parade platz in dem marine
geheimdienst den so genannten raum 39
aus seinem büro blickt fleming in
richtung der residenz des britischen
premierministers zu ministerien und zum
buckingham palace der marine
nachrichtendienst war ein wichtiger teil
der britischen geheimdienste
denn in jenen tagen war die marine das
große machtzentrum wenn die lady die
meere beherrscht dann war alles in
ordnung mit der britischen marine
nachrichtendienst galt commander fleming
als effizienter planer und organisator
von front missionen und als wichtiger
verbindungsmann zu anderen
geheimdiensten
doch er spürte dass er noch eine andere
berufung hatte da ist eine härtere seite
an james bond als bei ihm fleming war
ein kleiner romantiker als junger mann
hatte er gedichte geschrieben und
brauchte eine ganze weile um sich selbst
zu finden
er war ein ideengeber
guter administrator operetten soldat bei
der die drei landung wollte er dabei
sein aber etwas godfrey sagte das kann
ich nicht zulassen
sie wissen zu viel wenn sie in
gefangenschaft geraten und gegen ende
des krieges beginnt ihn sein
schreibtisch legen zu langweilen
und er sagt das weiß ich von einem
seiner kollegen im marine geheimdienst
dem sagt flemming er werde jetzt die
spionage geschichte schreiben die allen
spionagegeschichte nein inler setzt nach
dem krieg er wird fleming ein anwesen
auf jamaika und hofft es nach einer
geheim- operation gehen wollte schon
immer einen thriller schreiben das sagte
er mehreren freunden nach dem krieg mit
dem wissen dass er im geheimdienst
gesammelt hatte das wollte er schon
immer im januar 1952 auf jamaika steht
er vor einem neuen lebensabschnitt
in wenigen wochen wird er heiraten mit
44 jahren und erwartet mit seiner frau
in ein kind jetzt realisiert er seinen
großen traum in fleming war sehr gut
darin fantasiewelten aus fakten zu
erschaffen
sein natürlicher instinkt war es etwas
langweiliges aufzupolieren zu etwas
aufregendem er konnte nicht anders bei
allem was er schrieb stellte er sich
immer eine glamouröse version vor
als glamourös beschreibt fleming auch
den fuhrpark seines agenten 007 die
passion für sportwagen teils der
schriftsteller hier am steuer seines
viereinhalb liter in den james bond
roman tauchen immer wieder interessante
fahrzeuge haben wir jedoch zu anfang der
bentley roman goldfinger tauchte es
erstmal aston martin auf das war damals
ein sogenanntes beschrieben als die b
312 kinder waren in den eher trostlosen
zeiten großbritanniens nach dem krieg da
gab es viele entbehrungen und nicht sehr
viele autos die waren eher glanzlos ihn
hatte immer autos mit einem gewissen
extra einem aufgemotzten motor oder
suchen ein besuch von ihnen hatte immer
etwas besonderes einen kleinen funken
rennen zwischen den vielen großen und
war immer total fasziniert davon
dort hat auch im allerersten roman schon
vorher hatte auch schon bentley gefahren
überschlägt sich dann auch mal weil die
bösen da so eine nagel kette auf die
straße werfen
für das erste bond abenteuer casino
royal er schafft fleming einen
mysteriösen oberschurken le chiffre der
als agent für moskau in frankreich
agiert nach dem verlorenen casinospiel
foltert der bond brutal um sein geld
zurück zu erpressen
flemming beschreibt ihn als großen
unbekannten sein le chiffre wurde bei
kriegsende in dachau heimatlos
eingestuft das objekt behauptete
weiterhin unter totalem
gedächtnisverlust zu leiten
laut flemings fiktiven geheimdienst ossi
nutzt der bond gegner viele decknamen
und sprachen
er könnte franzose sein pole oder
deutscher herkunft unbekannt
[Musik]
flemming traf wirklich einen nerv
als er diese über gegner mit deutschem
hintergrund schuf da war etwas an dieser
sorte menschen das eher erschreckend
fand und der öffentlichkeit machten sie
auch angst in den 1950 er jahren in den
zeitungen in england und in amerika gab
es das allgemeine unwohlsein das zum
kriegsende gewisse hochrangige nazis
gestapo und ss irgendwie davon gekommen
waren dass diese irgendwie im normalen
leben abgetaucht waren
und niemand sie zur rechenschaft ziehen
es sind jene nazi-verbrechen die fleming
auch beim schreiben des martyriums von
bond durch le chiffre vor augen hat er
weiß von britischen agenten die auf
ihren missionen durch gestapo und ss
schwer gefoltert wurden
so steckt in flemmings scheinbar
dramatisch überzeichneten bond bösewicht
tatsächlich auch ein realer nazi
folterknecht des schiffes ungewöhnliche
erscheinung soll fleming ein
selbsternannter magier als vorbild
gedient haben
diese dient den britischen geheimdienst
1941 seine angeblich übersinnlichen
fähigkeiten an leicester crowley nannte
sich selbst sohn des satans
ich glaube seine mutter auch er war so
ein comic bösewicht wie er aussah und
wie er sich verhält
flemming hat ihn getroffen und gedacht
der ist perfekt denn merke ich mir
er hatte augen das weiß um seine
pupillen war groß und rund
er hatte so ein starren wie mussolini er
startete ich an wie ein wolf er war kein
schwergewicht schwitzig physisch
abstoßend und sexuell abnormen alles was
einen perfekten bond bösewicht ausmacht
war ein okkultes der 1930 er jahre
angeblich hatte ein baby geopfert aber
niemand kann das belegen
doch es gab einen mann der zum zittern
denn fragt wurde nach dem trolley in
einem hotelzimmer in brighton versucht
hatte den gott pan zu beschwören
crowley strahlte eine art macht aus eine
besondere wirkung
er kannte sich sehr gut mit astrologie
aus
die fleming slaski philip crowley
zeitweise in frankreich und deutschland
beide berauschen sich an sex und drogen
auch im vergleich mit der großen galerie
von bonns exzentrischen verrückten film
schurken wird bei der person crowleys
die realität bizarrer als die fiktion
das kann zusammen mit dingen die auch am
ende des krieges geschah große
fortschritte in der neuen wissenschaft
der plastischen chirurgie
man konnte sich nun tatsächlich in
jemand anderen verwandeln der chiffre
ist also nur eine nummer und die idee
war schon erschreckend dass man sein
aussehen völlig verändern konnte niemand
wusste wer du bist und man sein leben
unbehelligt fortführen könnte es war
eine große sache in den 50ern
die leute waren besorgt darüber
ian fleming hatte noch ein weiteres
vorbild für james bond und dessen casino
spiel gegen feindliche agenten für seine
spionage cocktail mixt der
schriftsteller mehrere reale agenten
charaktere war ich mal diese typen die
ich während meiner geheimdienst zeit
kennengelernt habe bestehend aus männern
in sonderkommandos alle die sind zu
einer balance verflochten und alle die
sind mein james bond geworden es gibt
nicht eine persönliche eine eine
spezielle person die genau das vorbild
für james bond wäre es beim schreiben
greift er auf seine erfahrung im
geheimdienst der admiralität fleming
erweckt charaktere zum leben die er
getroffen hatte agenten die in action
gewesen waren im fronteinsatz
die spur eines solchen echten agenten
auf geheimer mission führt nach
südamerika flemings kollege
marineoffizier office hat wird 1940 nach
brasilien entsandt um feindliche
deutsche aktivitäten auszukundschaften
die deutsche marine hatte umfangreiche
baupläne für größere kriegsschiffe sie
wollten die alliierten mit
schlachtschiffen im atlantik
herausfordern
mit der graf spee 1939 der bismarck und
der prinz eugen 1941 und der scham haus
der deutsche marine starb hielt es für
möglich mit einer politik der
einschüchterung und bündnisse ein system
von stützpunkten am atlantik zu schaffen
flemings marine geheimdienst hatte
agenten in allen regionen und häfen der
welt
die sollten schiffsbewegungen commander
es soll wohl auch herausfinden ob sich
ein pakt der brasilianischen regierung
mit nazi-deutschland anbahnt es gab auch
verbindungen zwischen deutschen
interessen und lateinamerikanischen
staaten die rechts gesinnt waren wie im
fall des brasilianischen vargas regimes
wenn man an james bond denkt kommt man
auf kartenspiele und die briten hatten
in jenem sommer 1940 auf globaler ebene
sehr schlechte karten auf der hand
agent ist hat ein gutes blatt in einem
casino hotel an der nordostküste trifft
er auf deutsche die ihr für nazi spione
hält sie messen sich beim pokerspiel
sein gegenüber ist wohl sein direkter
gegenspieler beim deutschen marine
geheimdienst ist auch einer dieser
charaktere bei marine geheimdienst der
eine ähnliche casino situation erlebt in
südamerika er wird in ein spiel
verwickelt und gewinnt dabei gegen
einige nazis meldet die casino
konfrontation an seine vorgesetzten nach
london
auch ian fleming liest seinen bericht
flemings meint so wie ich flemings
gedankenwelt bis zu einem gewissen grad
kenne ist das ein gutes beispiel wie er
die realität als fundament nimmt und sie
zu einer fantasievollen geschichte
ausbaut
es wird erinnerte sich dass der bond
erfinder ihn später interessiert zu
details seines kartenspiels in brasilien
aus fragte über den verlauf zum aussehen
und zu besonderen eigenschaften seiner
casino gegenspieler der mutmaßlichen
deutschen agenten düsseldorf izard waffe
fleming einer von mehreren waren james
bonds geben sowie dusan popov sie waren
die echten agenten auf gefährlichen
missionen auch hinter bonds erstem
endgegner steckten als vorbilder echte
megalomanen nazi agentin und
kriegsverbrecher sie brachten die wahren
007 in tödliche gefahr in casino royale
verarbeitet ian fleming auch eigene
erlebnisse aus seiner agentin zeit im
krieg auch er war ein teil von james
bond fleming hat diese casino geschichte
auch in seine persönliche mythologie
eingearbeitet
als angeblicher teil seiner biografie
bevor er sie weiter ab wandelt und james
bond auf den leib schreibt im roman
casino royale
knapp zwei jahre nach der premiere des
ersten kinofilms um seinen agenten
stirbt ian fleming die bolt mania der
sechziger das ganze popkultur phänomen
007 erlebte james bond schöpfer nur in
anfängen
ich glaube ihm fleming wäre schier
erstaunt dass wir hier sitzen nach all
dieser zeit dass der name james bond
wirklich so bekannt ist das
erfolgsrezept hatte ian fleming
angerührt echte geheim missionen und
charaktere der kriegszeit gewürzt mit
fantasie glamour und spannendem schüler
das war sein james bond cocktail
[Musik]